the difference between the creation of
the chronic and being around that and
just the creation of doggy style
what was the energy difference in your
opinion being somebody who was there for
both like
the chronic
you really didn't know
uh
where to go
you know uh dr dre will critique records
for us
you know he always told me during the
chronic i got a record strictly for you
corrupt i was like wow
i made it right he's making a record but
his album strictly for me i was like
so you know i was excited and just
watching them as they're creating the
album itself in general one of the first
records i heard was a [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] gun
and gta
and so it was like bam those was the two
and he was just creating as he went then
one day he came to me and said here i
got this for you krup you gonna set this
off i was like damn let me hear it and
all you heard was wet
wet
and i said oh my god he smiled at me
yeah
and that [ __ ] came on and i was just oh
my god because this is me all right and
that's why i started that off dr dre
hand picked that for me he made it for
me
rbx and rage
you know what i mean stranded on death
row
and snoop was the superstar so you know
he already had it planned
you know how he wanted it to be who he
wanted to start it off corrupt you're
going to start this off this is go after
that it was lyrical gang bang
and then [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] was the last
record we made which is basically he
showed us that you could take one beat
take all the music off keep two pieces
of it the drums the bass line maybe one
other piece
and make a whole new record they won't
even know it
right they're the same
so he stripped down g thing remix
and that's [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] he took
everything off except for the
key thing and then the boom boom boom
and the drums
and made [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] and he also
taught me something too because my verse
i started off [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] but
hoes and tricks like when these nuts and
sucked i was rapping it though dog is
all melody he told me melody
and then snoop and dre heard heard me
saying it and he was like hold on
up say that again
all right go lay that that's the hook
that's that's that part
snoop add that whoop to it and so you
know snoop came to me say corrupt say it
like this don't say [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
but hoes and tricks don't do it like
that do it like this [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
but hoes and tricks
licked on these nuts add that melody to
it throw up so i did it like that and he
changed the couple words i had
boom and that was that's the hook me and
snoop and i was like wow so now i got
this record here while i'm having fun i
was a battle rapper
so stranded on death row and lyrical
gang bang that was like right up your
alley white am i out this was new i'm
like oh okay you know adding some melody
into your all of that type of fancy [ __ ]
and i'm like okay boom and i did it and
it was like wow you know what i'm gonna
be a star
then when it came to doggy style our
confidence was at the moon we already
knew where we were going
we already knew what dr dre expected
will make sure smiling knows the key
make sure you smile
and know what you're doing you get money
satisfied dr dre and you golden and that
was the key to dog because he knew how
to do it like this oh add this to it
because he was the he was the key
so first person to make smile is snoop
so you know who bam and that's no doggy
style we was all
confident we knew where to go
and that's why you could tell the
difference in that than the chronic on
that one we was critiqued
yeah and signed and we had and science
you had some cheese in your pocket you
know
yeah yeah yeah you guys got something a
little bit of fame from the chronic and
then me and dad's created the dog pound
and dog
chronic dog food
the dog pound
[Music]